pewdie i want to ask you this question
you know what what can what can a
typical
you know what can the typical citizen do
i mean when we're looking at all these
different things
how can they after we we saw what
happened during the elections
what can the typical citizen the typical
person watching this right now
outside of just listening to the show
how can you get more active how can get
more involved because
if they're going to sit you know we
can't sit back and say somebody else is
going to fix this problem
which a lot of people just love to do
tweet send a text send them email
is there anything more proactively can
do oh don't fall for the trap
man do not fall for the trap of relying
on the government in any way
don't fall for the trap become as
independent as possible
become a self earner go create your own
value in a marketplace educate yourself
don't get emotionally tied to a
political party just because your
parents are
republicans or democrats or you know
whatever they are look my parents were
christians but i was an atheist for 25
years i chose to go become a christian
because i wanted to go study
i looked at judaism i looked at
christianity i looked at lds i thought
the best thing for me was
non-denominational christian right my
parents
politically they were on complete
opposite sides i went and chose to see
you've been voting democrat all your
life then you're voting republican maybe
you're an independent because it doesn't
seem like you fully agree with
everything republicans do you don't
fully agree with everything democrats do
hey go independent like an eagle flies
faster if he's traveling like this right
with both wings yeah so if we're going
like this if we're going like this we're
just going in circles if we're like this
for far left if we're like this we're
still doing circles just so you know far
right it's going in the same place right
far left the eagle's still doing it for
our place but like this we're
we're making real progress when we're
sitting here right so
as a as a viewer listening to this if
what we say or i say or adam says or
sam matt says you fully disagree with
great
go do some more research okay i fully
agree with
great go find even more leaks i stated
my 20
then i said be the devil's advocate
because it's not like i don't know a
hundred percent
i think it's an idea let's now tear the
idea apart
right patrick lencioni who we're having
at the event he's got this one book
called
uh four qualities of extraordinary
executive i think it's something like
that i had my entire executive team read
it at the home office we went through it
one of the things he talks about argue
argue which to me it's what debate
debate debate debate debate debate
conflict until eventually you do what
you sit there and say
you know what once we're on the same
page he says move forward don't bring it
up anymore
okay let's just go and move forward
we're all on the same page you won his
ideas better
great let's go we're moving on right i
think
this leads me to the whole challenge
that we're facing right now with this
whole cancer culture bill burr got up
and he said one joke and everybody's
like hey
billboard's not getting cancelled you
know the other actress got cancelled and
then
you know who's the guy from uh uk got
canceled what are you talking about he's
one of the best tv guys
i didn't say he's one of the most
likable tv guys he's one of the best tv
guys he everybody talks about
morgan pierce morgan is on t you know
everybody talks about that's exactly who
you want
if i'm running good morning britain
that's exactly the kind of guy i want
you don't want a vanilla guy
hi i'm john i'm like this pretty boy
white guy who says all the proper things
[ __ ] i want peers
yeah i was pierced for his opinion but
the point is so what if you disagree he
doesn't agree
with that megan told the truth he has
the right to say
i don't believe her right so we we have
to kind of uh
know that this is a trap that you can't
fall for
you know sometimes a trap helps the
people in your own party
but what you don't realize long term
you're next it's gonna come back to you
and haunt you and uh the biggest thing
is don't fall for the trap go become
independent be a self-earner
protect your own family or you don't
have to one day look back and say i
cannot believe i made a decision i'm now
you know having to worry about that you
know i have to be
answering to someone's policies i don't
know i think
to me i had a guy over at my house with
his wife
sunday night and i love these guys their
kids are over three kids and
we're talking i said look you have to
know one thing about my style of
leadership
here's how i work and here's how
conflict started
okay just so you know i ask you who you
want to be
i ask you what you want i ask you how
serious you're about it
once you commit in my mind i help you
get there and i'm your advisor to help
you get there
conflict happens when you change yours
every two months
and when you don't want to commit to
your word then there's a conflict
i said so who do you want to be because
at the pace we're going right now this
is just not going to work out
just telling you right it's not going to
work out you change every other day
so we sat down we hash it at 90 minutes
boom
we're moving forward we're in a good
place right okay great same thing goes
with
you know like today where we are dude we
got to make up our minds about what
we're going to be doing and what
direction we're going but we got to have
the debate we got to hash it out we got
to sit down and have the conversation
and then all of a sudden say hey we're
on the same page let's move on now you
know so in the marketplace today if you
want to be somebody that's seen as a
leader
you you kind of got to go earn your
stripes in the market today go on them
easiest time ever to become a rich
ever what do you mean by that why do you
say the easiest time to ever become rich
this is a joke right now to become
wealthy you give me somebody that's
willing to read and willing to work hard
they're gonna get the strategies and the
stamina okay
if you show me somebody that's going to
work hard and improve it's the easiest
time ever to become wealthy there's so
many ways why do you think that is right
now you're saying
money's everywhere today money's i've
looked at a house okay
okay one house i look at 25 million
dollars what does the owner do
oh the owner is the founder of the
lights on the bottom of the shoes that
when you kids would run the lights would
come up he's a billionaire
get out of here like yeah so i've looked
at 20 homes in the last
however long that are all 25 million
plus right 20 million plus right
wow what does he do he uh ac company
what does he do this one yo everyone
knows who this he has a drink company
okay like what famous tequila okay what
does he do
this what does he do okay he was one of
the shareholders of berkshire hathaway
what does he do he was an executive of
ibm in the 80s
what does he do he was this what does he
do you
like yeah there's so many ways to make
money right now go
find a guy like him work as his
right-hand guy
earn the respect of his shadow
everything he does
and then five ten years later it's
happening to you the hardest part is
finding the right people to shadow it is
by far the biggest
challenge today if a young guy forget
industry if i have to choose between
industry and individual to shadow i'm
shadowing the individual not the
industry
go shadow the right individual forget
about the industry people are too much
about
find your passion find your this no find
your team find your running mates forget
about that
find your running mates finance your
passion this whole thing about go
find your passion no i finance my
passion
i don't find my passion my passion is
baseball cards
but to me i'm gonna finance my passion
yesterday we're going through
your cards your your collection yeah a
little bit of it a little bit of the
collection yesterday
you know so finance your passion but
find your running mates
find a team to run with well what's
shocking a couple years ago to your
first vault conference
i was shocked by the young man who was
15 years old
and uh he mowed all the lawns to take he
and his dad too crazy of all conferences
teenage 14 15 years old it's also
shocking to me when i read
the comments that follow valuetainment
listen to the bet david
podcast is how many teenagers are now
listening
but also making a lot of money thirty
thousand forty thousand fifty thousand
teenagers yep i'm i'm floored
flabbergasted so
it's not an age thing it's a desire
thing an education thing
an execution thing following through and
sticking with it and not
uh not wavering on your commitments did
you think you could you know when
you were going to start making two
million a year did you think you're
gonna make you and china are gonna make
two million a year when you're live all
of a sudden right now like the kind of
life you're living in the house you're
living the roles parked outside the kids
going to the schools
having the last shot big shot in the
dark i'm getting a meal in there one day
without saying okay what's the strategy
then once you gave me strategy then it's
just a matter of time
that's that's that's the cool part about
this you can just walk your way into
you know a an income goal based on
time effort and sticking with it the
biggest thing i see and just
what you just mentioned people just
wavering uh once they face conflict uh
okay that's not what i really wanted and
we do something else yeah that's not
what i really wanted to do something
that's i've never seen the book
outwitting the devil
that's called it being a drifter they
drift from here they drift from here
they
never accomplished anything look back in
their whole entire life said man i get
regret
but in the meantime i've been you know
trolling people online and dogging
people out online but really never
accomplished anything myself versus
stand focused on number two three and
four you know you should be focusing on
or instead of focus on number one you
should be focusing on
your game in in in getting better and
improving
and that's exactly what you and china
have done continuously which is pretty
insane to see that happen and anyways
jack hassell just gave 50 dollars and
said
trump didn't win didn't focus on the
democratic voters big mistake if he did
spend
the time to speak to them he very well
would still be president next republican
candidate needs to speak to the
democratic audience to secure wins but
david 20 24.
i agree with jack on both
sides they need to speak to the other
side in 2024 somebody needs to be able
to do that
jack i i i would have the conversation
about running
but i was born in iran i think it's very
important for people to realize i will
make a great advisor okay and i
you know all the other stuff but one day
if somebody like you wants to run
okay somebody like matt wants to run
somebody like a guy in bakersfield
what's his name i forget his name
your name is
get out of here ricky aguilar no we're
calling you out pace is dead
no he doesn't get out of here every time
i text him he's like new phone number
who's this i'm like come on ricky
don't make me uh cancel culture you bro
but let me just say one thing
sure uh and this is a kudos right here
because you said something
very powerful that i actually fully
agree with and i'm sure matt will as
well you said
don't if if i had the choice of picking
my field or the person to run with
the person to run with versus a field
i'm going to take the person to run with
let's use you as a case example how long
did you do insurance 14. before you met
pat
yep 14 years 14 years and you did okay
you maybe made six figures
here and there 350 being away all right
you met pat
something changed click completely right
so it was the person you were running
with
you were still doing insurance but it
was a vision
it was a purpose it was a passion there
was a system
it was the person you run with you know
for me
i was living in south beach i was
running around doing whatever hanging
with who whatever whatever
i had to get out of my comfort zone and
said dude
the people that i'm hanging with in
south beach are not going to get me to
the next level i need to get to and i
moved
to freaking boca when i was 26 years old
and started running with adults
guys who were in their mid-30s started
to have families kids uh my buddy mark
who's
my business partner now i was his like
junior associate
cold caller just you know minimum wage
guy that he taught me the ropes i had to
have some humility and say look this
guy's
killing it i need to shut the f up and
just listen from this guy he's ultimate
salesman and now
you know years later 15 years later our
firm is is great it's awesome but
i had to have the humility to say look
i'm 26 dude i don't know everything
you know i might get cool points for
being in the club but not in the
business world
so it's very powerful what pat said so
for the young people out there
you know it's not about your passion
it's about
getting focused on a career decision and
a career move
running running mates that can take you
to the next level
and i mean i'll even use my case example
for myself i was doing my own little
show
sas talks money on social media i didn't
have a clear direction of where i wanted
to go
aligning myself with pbd and
valuetainment
like you know exactly where you're going
and running mates
are so keys for so for young people out
there 20 million views
think about it you've had 20 million
eyeballs since you joined by wow
that's insane that's crazy 20 million
eyeballs
how often when you go out people stop
you know okay so boy hey
all the time either soyboy mafia or [ __ ]
whatever the point i'm trying to make to
you is
the point i'm trying to make to you is
find the right running mate
get into that team the right team can
change your life
then you can finance your passion
correct if it's movies you'll fund your
movie
right if it's motorcycles you fund your
bikes if it's collectibles you're funded
if it's
anything you'll fund it but get in the
right circle and running
totally do you have a few markers you
want to share to how to make sure you're
picking the right team the right
uh to me characters have the character
has to be at the top guys and principles
because
you know i can also tell you uh uh
when i was 21 years old i got out of the
army and i was temper was high
and i had respect in the streets because
i had a little bit of a reputation
so a guy from colombia a guy
a guy from bally's who introduced me to
a guy from colombia who was
one of the biggest dealers in california
and he was
selling stuff from colombia and you know
what they sell from colombia a coffee
high-end websites right
coffee yeah of course so so him and i
meet he says hey you know we need to go
for a job tonight and if you do this
we'll pay you know such and such money
was a good amount cash
and i'm like okay what do we need to do
so we went to marina uh
del rey and uh we went to one of the
yachts
collected some money was a hundred
thousand dollars and it was you know
big website a nose candy mountain on the
table sitting there and
we left he says 4k every week okay i
would have made money
but i was six to 12 months away from
going to jail you would have never heard
about patrick david
so the running mates need to also be
solid
values and principles and character you
cannot compromise
that part that's also the fastest way to
ruin your life
and you will get a sense if it's the
right crowd or the wrong crowd
you will get a sense you will know
you're not a dummy we know
when we're in a place where like ooh i'm
having a little too much fun takes this
going a little too fast
and i don't know if long term i admire
that i want to be that man one day or
that woman one day it's fun for the
moment
but yeah long term and what's crazy is
we know at a young age
yeah you know at a young age like you
know at eight years old
it's not even like you learn this at 22
years old you know
like ah it's a little too dangerous here
what i'm doing with these guys you know
this could lead me to
you know some trouble so um yeah i think
you gotta also find that part
and you know it's it's almost like
you're uh
a girlfriend that you will show publicly
where you're gonna bring to your parents
and hey mom look at this girl i just met
her look at this guy just man
there's got to be something where you're
proud to show them to your parents okay
you're proud to show your running mates
to your parents saying hey these are the
guys i'm in business with too sure
if you can do that then guess what you
got something you can
bank on and if you find something like
that rule of thumb don't
screw it up don't screw it up
be a valuable asset to that group so
you're also contributing so if you
enjoyed this little short segment from
the podcast that we did here's another
short segment to watch or if you want to
see the entire podcast
click over here take care everybody bye